bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag petite
devinette
elle crée du lien social défendre les
intérêts locaux diffuse des vidéos ou
permet tout simplement de partager un
loisir ou une passion elles se sont
laids les assistantes sociales mais non
les associations elles sont 2344 sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
qui sont-elles comment sont elles créent
et subventionné quel est le rôle des
communes et de l'agglomération je vous
propose un tour complet de l'horizon
associatif saint quentinois c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est la rentrée la reprise du travail
la rentrée scolaire les associations ou
fait de même les forums se sont
terminées ces jours ci et nous y étions
à l'instar des saint-quentinoise et des
50 y voit qu'ils étaient nombreux à
s'être déplacés
[Musique]
association sportive avec démonstrations
à l'appui associations éducatives
sociales culturelles elles étaient
toutes là comme chaque année les saint
quentinois était venu reprendre contact
se renseigner se réinscrit ou changer
d'activité pour cette nouvelle année et
à chacun la sienne bon bah moi ça va
être le squash cette année récents les
ateliers d'écriture mon fils il est
intéressé par leur le foot handball
et arts plastiques pour de danse
classique pour ma fille elle va faire de
la gymnastique rythmique multisports
pour petit puis le basket pour moi la
marche nordique du football féminin pour
ma fille oui ça fait beaucoup
d'activités je pense que pour profiter
de la vie profitez-en c'est le mot nous
l'avons fait nous aussi en nous rendant
dans les locaux de quelques associations
à commencer par l'aïkido à montigny le
bretonneux
créé en 1981 le club compte aujourd'hui
une dizaine de bénévoles dont sept
professeurs un président un trésorier et
un secrétaire
l'année qui vient de s'écouler a
enregistré 111 adhérents moitié enfants
moitié adultes le club propose des cours
des cinq ans avec cette année un cours
dédié aux seniors le samedi mais au fait
c'est quoi l'aïkido alors l'aïkido est
un art martial japonais
uniquement défensives c'est-à-dire qu'on
cherche pas à renvoyer la violence que
peut nous donner l'autre au contraire on
cherche plutôt que d'aller dans les
oppositions de se mettre avec lui
[Musique]
un état d'esprit non violent qui se mêle
parfaitement avec la vie de quartier car
la discipline vise à rassembler plutôt
qu'à diviser pas question ici de former
des guerriers ou un esprit de
compétition mais plutôt de réduire la
violence avec un engagement de chaque
instant c'est quelque chose que je fais
par passion avec tout mon coeur et qui
donc prend en prend du temps comme tous
les bénévoles dans les associations
autre engagement autre passion le club
de boxe américaine d'elancourt créé en
1991 par son président actuel alain il
met le club accumule les graines de
champions avec plusieurs titres de
champion france et d'europe à son actif
l'association jouit d'un joli palmarès
ici les poings et les pieds sont
utilisés et les coups sont portés mais
solidarité et rassemblements demeurent
les jeunes qu'ils arrivent tous les ans
c'est bien qu'il ya quelque chose qui
les attire et c'est bien que quand ils
viennent comme ça tous les ans
qu'on ait 30 40 personnes à pratiquer ce
sport
même sans avoir de champion c'est une
mobilisation c'est une communication
c'est la semaine dernière c'est très
important
au quotidien pas de chacun pour soi dans
son discours de reprise le président
rappelle qu'on ne laisse pas un jeune
seul à l'issue du court on prévient en
cas d'absence et l'on vient s'entraîner
régulièrement les hommes et les femmes
viennent si évacuer le stress de la vie
quotidienne et se défouler mais pas
seulement transmettre une passion et des
valeurs est tout aussi important en
créant son club alain willommet a
souhaité suivre les pas de son frère
aîné qui avait lui même créé son club de
boxe à issy les moulineaux du bénévolat
c'est très compliqué c'est comme si on
passait à la fois beau et color dise
voilà voilà sur ce qu'on fait est ce que
ça vous intéresse si ça vous intéresse
venez avec nous on est là voilà c'est à
hauteur de vos attentes on va on va le
faire tous s'en sort le mieux promesse
tenue puisque un futur champion olivier
barbot va tenter sa chance cette année
et concourir avec le soutien du
président en personne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autant entraînements tout aussi intensif
celui du groupe vocal imagine à la
maison des chorales de montigny le
bretonneux avec un petit échauffement
pour commencer et dans la bonne humeur à
l'arrivée du chef de choeur marie flore
mas et là ça devient très sérieux tout
le monde prend son cahier interrogation
surprise sur nougayork et devant lé
nouveau auditionné qui feront peut-être
prochainement partie du groupe marie
fleur my donne le ton et impulser le
rythme et l'énergie du coeur à
l'association lancé en 1995 compte
environ 30 adhérents par an pas plus
équilibre de la chorale oblige une
chorale qui se renouvelle chaque année
j'ai écouté plein de gens ce soir pour
avoir un peu des nouvelles têtes en
groupe alors il est important d'avoir
des d aberrant un maximum d'adhérents
qui viennent de montigny ça pour la
mairie c'est important nous faut des
gens qui
chantent juste qu'ils aient sens du
rythme ensuite tout est question
d'équilibré dans le groupe en ce début
de rentrée soprane altier basses et
ténors sont les bienvenus esprits
chagrins s'abstenir ici on chante en
rimes et en rire tout le monde s'entend
bien et tout le monde est heureux de
venir chanter ils se retrouvent et c'est
vraiment un groupe très sympa
[Applaudissements]
une association c'est aussi l'occasion
d'un véritable engagement y attrape
aînés de l'envy d'éduquer autrement dans
le respect de l'environnement
l'association fête ses 10 ans cette
année dix ans d'investissements dans des
actions éducatives pour essayer de
transformer la société un peu au jour le
jour c'est vraiment défendre une autre
éducation
basée sur la pédagogie active qui puisse
permettre des transformations sociales
et écologiques pour un monde plus
solidaire et responsable il grain
accompagne les populations tout au long
de l'année l'association collabore
également avec les mairies les écoles
les centres de loisirs les enseignants
les syndicats de traitement d'ordures
ménagères ou encore les entreprises ces
acteurs sont sensibilisés au
développement durable par le biais
d'ateliers d'outils pédagogiques de jeux
de rôle ou jeux interactifs ou par le
biais de bandes dessinées tri des
déchets qualité de l'air qualité de
l'eau commerce équitable les maîtres
nous ici réflexion et envie d'agir on va
chercher à donner de déclic aux gens
pour leur donner envie d'agir par
rapport à l'environnement mais au fait
comment les saint quentinois agissent
pour leur environnement nous sommes
allés leur poser la question laiterie
déjà des déchets jeu peu importe où
pendant leurs deux voitures ont essayé
d'économiser l'eau et l'électricité on
peut rouler au vélo à l'âme au travail à
pied puis de covoiture éduquer les
jeunes
ils reprennent le flambeau pour éviter
les pesticides manger bio il graines des
pages d'une association comme les autres
d'associations bénévoles elle est
devenue créatrice d'emplois aujourd'hui
vingt personnes sont salariées sur
l'antenne de trappes et au total c'est
une trentaine de personnes qui
travaillent tous ri graines dans toute
la france s'ajoute à cela une centaine
de bénévoles qui oeuvrent pour la
planète si vous souhaitez vous aussi
vous impliquez sachez que i graines pour
ses dix ans on sera une grande campagne
pour la fin de l'année une campagne
ponctuée d'événements et de surprises
jusqu'à la fin de l'été 2010 est jusqu'à
l'été 2010 est justement vous pourrez
profiter de l'activité que vous vous
êtes choisi en cette rentrée sportive
culturelle environnementale les
associations de saint quentin en
yvelines sont nombreuses et diverses et
en constante évolution
les 2340 quatre associations sont
implantés au sein des différents
quartiers de l'agglomération et regroupe
quarante mille bénévoles elles sont 22
dans le domaine culture et patrimoine
20% dans le secteur social et logement
14% oeuvre pour la société et la
citoyenneté 14% sont dans le sport 11%
dans les loisirs et tourisme l'éducation
la formation et la recherche concentre
9% des associations et elles sont 6 % à
agir pour l'économie et l'aide à
l'emploi le tissu associatif saint
quentinois riche de cette diversité
jouit d'une belle vitalité une vitalité
renforcé par le soutien de
l'agglomération qui en 2015 a versé 3
millions sept cent soixante dix mille
euros de subventions aux associations du
territoire dans le même temps plus de
180 créations ont vu le jour 35 à traves
28 à plaisir 24 à guyancourt
vingt-et-une pour montigny le bretonneux
et 15 à villepreux un secteur qui ne
connaît pas la crise et qui se trouve
renforcée par le nouveau périmètre à 12
communes parmi les associations toute
neuve et y'a plaisir du commerce à
plaisir justement une association qui
revêt un statut particulier puisqu'il
s'agit d'une association de commerçants
et d'ailleurs ça sert à quoi une
association de commerçants je pense pour
les droits de
l'information pour lutter contre les
jets pas les loyers ont offert une
association des connaissances à des fins
d'un commerçant aurait des solutions
pour développer justement le commerce
qui m
subi
cela
bravo en effet le commerce de proximité
est source de rayonnement économique il
permet aussi de s'intégrer plus
facilement à son quartier à sa commune
afin d'avoir une réponse plus détaillée
nous sommes allés à la rencontre
d'aurélien le puise président de
l'association en question donc déjà le
but c'est que tous les commerçants se
connaissent
d après le but secret du flux dans le
commerce avec nous avec les habitants de
plaisir tout simplement et leur faire
connaître justement tous ces commerces
et qu'ils puissent consommer plus un
plaisir et qu'ils aillent pas plus
ailleurs et qui reste chez nous
pas simple à faire car la ville de
plaisir et la plus étendue des yvelines
pour cela à chéquier commerçants va être
mise en place ce chéquier permettra aux
plaisirs wa d'avoir des coupons de
réductions dans leurs commerces de
proximité et aux commerçants de se faire
connaître la preuve aux habitants qui
arrive qu'ils savent pas tout ce qui se
passe dans la vie d'un ben c'est pas le
commerce couramment créer un lien je
pense que c'est vraiment une obligation
et qui on n'a pas le choix si on veut y
est une ville dynamique on n'a pas le
choix de passer par une association
créée il ya un an avec l'appui de la
mairie de plaisir l'association regroupe
aujourd'hui plus de 80 commerçants sur
les cent dix que compte la ville un vrai
succès est déjà temps de projets à venir
outre le chéquier les commerçants
envisagent de fêter halloween de décorer
leurs vitrines à l'identique pour les
fêtes de fin d'année mais aussi de créer
la fête du patrimoine des commerçants
pur plaisir l'aventuré ne fait que
commencer
tous ces exemples d'engagement et de
réussite font envie certes mais comment
se lancer et créé son association
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a mis en place le guichet
unique afin de proposer un
accompagnement sur mesure aux porteurs
de projets voici quelques conseils aux
futurs créateurs
souvent le premier réflexe est de se
tourner vers l'amérique mais le guichet
unique mis en place par l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines il ya un an
est un point d'entrée intercommunale à
la fois pour les demandes de subventions
mais aussi pour le conseil et
l'accompagnement global au sein de
guichet unique une personne qui peuvent
recevoir qui peut vous aider sur
quelles sont les démarches à suivre des
statuts comment il rédige ce qui est
important on peut vous envoyer aussi
d'un des experts pourront aider sur
aussi là le recrutement outre un conseil
direct l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines met à disposition un centre
de documentation afin de renseigner les
futurs dirigeants d'associations et
d'ici la fin du mois de septembre les
dossiers de demandes de subventions
seront mises en ligne pour 2017 dans le
cadre de l'élargissement du territoire
l'agglomération a souhaité harmoniser sa
politique aux douze communes dès janvier
prochain de nouveaux critères devront
être observée afin de pouvoir bénéficier
de ces subventions comme l'entente entre
plusieurs associations ou la mise en
place d'un projet commun l'agglomération
organise également les 5 et 6 octobre
prochain une formation sur les
stratégies commerciales des associations
employeurs une autre formation portera
sur la mutualisation entre associations
les 15 et 16 novembre
vous pouvez aussi retrouver toutes les
procédures juridiques sur internet que
vous souhaitez créer une association
simple ou employeurs très belle rentrée
à toutes et à tous ciao
[Musique]